[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALICIA WILLIAMS: In
this video, we're
going to walk through how
to manage user permissions
for the payments profile tied
to your Google Cloud billing
account.
If you're looking to
give users permission
to update your payment method,
billing address, or payment
contacts, you'll
need to grant them
permissions on the
payments profile associated
with your billing account.
Your billing account
and payments profile
are separate entities
that work together.
The billing account
tracks the costs
incurred by all
attached projects
and defines who pays
for the resources.
It is connected to a
payments profile, which
stores your payment
instrument information
and defines how you
pay for charges.
A payments profile can be linked
to multiple payment accounts
across Google products, such as
Google Workspace, Google Cloud,
Google Ads, and more.
Let's walk through
what permissions
are available for the payments
profile and how to update them.
Get started by heading
into the Cloud Console.
You can start on your
organization or any project
homepage, then head
to the navigation
menu in the left-hand pane.
Choose Billing, and then
click Manage Billing Accounts.
If you land in a Billing
Overview page, which
looks like this, you can
navigate to Manage Billing
Accounts by expanding
the dropdown
list of Billing Accounts.
Now select the billing account.
Navigate to the
Payment settings page.
You'll need to be
a billing account
administrator or viewer
on the billing account
to see this page.
Then, under Payments users,
click Manage payments users.
Note-- to be able to manage
users and permissions
for the payments profile,
you must yourself
have manage users or admin with
all permissions level access
for the payments profile.
If you need this
access, please reach out
to the existing
payments profile admins.
Here, you can expand the
details for an existing user
to update permissions
or to remove the user.
You can also click
to add a new user.
You can set
permissions for users
at several levels,
each building on top
of the prior permissions.
Read access allows users to
view the payments profile.
Edit payments profile allows
users to view and edit
the payments profile.
Sign-up and purchase
allows users
to link the payments profile
with additional Google
products.
Manage users allows
users to add and update
users and permissions for
those payments profile.
Admin with all permissions
has all current and future
permissions for the
payments profile.
To set the admin
permission for a user,
you must be an admin on
this payments profile.
Users with the manage
users permission
can set only up to the
same permissions they are
granted on their user account.
When you are finished setting
up permissions for the user,
click Invite for new users
or Save for existing users.
Congratulations.
You can now manage permissions
for the payments profile tied
to your Cloud billing account.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]